the sort of cold and crisp day when
christmas markets feel like a natural
place to go but in vienna they are
closed locked down
like the nation
the stall where maria sells her
chestnuts is now shuttered for at least
10 days and maybe 20.
it's so sad
hard i'm angry all things
many people
say
corona don't live here
they want they don't want vaccina
and
many people they go on the streets and
say no no covet but
you can see in the hospitals
austrians have been told to stay at home
and to only go out for essential reasons
it is the best solution um to do in
lacton but of course
i think everybody who is vaccinated is
frustrated
the cause of all this is a sharp rise in
covid cases a desire to stem a wave that
is crashing over the country and much of
the continent
we're certainly concerned with respect
to the numbers and i guess the hard
times are still coming within the next
two to four weeks we expect to see the
peak levels of hospital admissions and
this will be a hard two months but
hopefully if enough people get
vaccinated from then on it will be much
easier and we will follow the path of
other countries
but lockdown is a vague word and the
streets are not deserted
there are still a lot of people milling
around the heart of this city day one of
this lockdown
feels very different from the lockdowns
of
last year and maybe that's because
there's still a great swathe of the
austrian population that just doesn't
think the government had the right to go
ahead with these new restrictions
there have been big protests against
this lockdown
a third of people here are not
vaccinated and they expect to face
specific restrictions in the future
but even those who have taken the jab
are sometimes suspicious
when we're saying that it's 95 effective
at the beginning we're seeing that's
definitely not the case now we're saying
no more lockdowns yet we're in lockdowns
now how can we really trust the
information that's been you know being
given to us at the moment
i'm vaccinated but i did it just because
we had this rule
where we can only get into bars and
restaurants and stuff
with
vaccination
austria is making vaccination
mandatory in the coming months in the
face of another wave of infection
europe's resolve to battle covid
is taking a tougher edge
adam parsons sky news vienna